[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti
Vorrei partire
facendo e ponendovi due domande alle
quali vorrei che voi rispondeste sia
adesso sia al termine del mio discorso
per capire se effettivamente questo
discorso potrebbe essere un cambiamento
anche in voi La prima domanda è bisogna
perdersi per poi ritrovarsi
e l'altra domanda è questa tre semplici
oggetti
come un'albicocca
uno smalto rosso
e l'immagine del mare possono queste tre
semplici cose cambiare la vita di
qualcuno
Provate a rispondere
Ecco come potete vedere dalla mia prima
slide E da quello che è stato la lettura
del mio abstract partiamo da questo
dall'essere umani siamo esseri umani che
ci evolviamo nel tempo perché perché
l'ambiente cambia e quindi siamo
obbligati a cambiare con esso
l'evoluzione è fatta di periodi di
transizione nei quali dobbiamo
affrontare delle Sfide con noi stessi e
in Queste sfide dobbiamo perdere una
parte di noi per acquisirne una nuova ma
allo stesso tempo dobbiamo avere una
forte consapevolezza rispetto a quello
che noi siamo a quelli che sono i nostri
veri valori a quelli che ci definiscono
Io oggi nonostante tutto quello che mi è
successo Sono rimasto sempre Marina
quando mi chiedono tu chi sei io sono
prima di tutto Marina
naturalmente queste fasi di cambiamento
possono arrivare
quando uno meno ce l'aspetta e questo
cambiamento implica anche la paura la
paura del cambiamento
implica uno stress perché perché tutto
questo ci Attiva ci rende più pronti e
questo non è un fatto in sé negativo è
evoluzionisticamente positivo perché ci
rende più pronti
questo qui ci prepara al nostro
cambiamento
Ecco quest'onda
questo onda perché poi ve lo spiegherò
Però partiamo da questo i periodi di
transizione possono arrivare con eventi
che sono
e arrivano e possono essere sia positivi
che negativi
e ci obbligano a cambiare e invece ci
sono eventi sia positivi che negativi
che invece noi ricerchiamo perché
vogliamo un cambiamento nella nostra
vita tipo sono si scrive all'università
lo fa perché vuole cambiare vuole
diventare qualcun altro oppure se invece
ti capita la morte di qualcuno che te
vicino oppure la diagnosi malattia
questi sono eventi che sono drammatici e
che cambiano la nostra vita e ci
obbligano a cambiare in qualche modo la
nostra vita
perché vi ho messo quest'onda quest'onda
l'ho messa perché voglio parlarvi della
storia di qualcuno che ha spiegato
benissimo Come affrontare un evento
positivo in sé ma che può avere una
declinazione sia positiva che negativa e
lo fa attraverso quello che è la sua
vita il suo sport Voglio portarvi
l'esempio di Kelly Slater che è uno tra
i più grandi famosi surfisti nel mondo e
io dico anche una leggenda nello sport e
vi do questa testimonianza a partire da
un documentario nel quale lui parla del
suo più grande sogno che era quello di
vincere cinque titoli mondiali
consecutivi e parla della l'ultima
competizione nel 1998 al Pipe Master
alle Hawaii nel quale
lui praticamente dopo una stazione una
stagione un po' fatta di non dico
successi ma comunque sia aveva perso la
il divertimento la voglia di fare il suo
sport in qualche modo e pensava anche
quasi di ritirarsi
Beh in quella competizione lui si
giocava il suo Quinto mondiale il sogno
che aveva sempre da piccolo Beh in quel
giorno praticamente i suoi due più
grandi avversari vanno male sulle onde
non riescono a dare il meglio di sé e
quindi in quel momento che cosa succede
per noi c'è un'opportunità lui sa ad
avere in mano tutto quanto sai che se
lui fa bene lui Arriverà al suo sogno di
una vita no E in quel momento invece
cosa ha un crollo nervoso non riesce a
respirare quel momento lui che fa si fa
aiutare da un suo amico un surfista
riprende la concentrazione
lo aiuta con gli esercizi di
respirazione con un po' di Yoga No sono
surfisti quindi sono un po' Naif però
sanno cosa fare lo sportivo sta sempre
cosa fare ma chiede aiuto nel momento
del bisogno Beh in quel momento lui ha
ripreso la concentrazione e ha ripreso a
respirare è entrato in acqua
e in quel momento ho trovato quello
stato di Flow quello stato che tanti
sportivi cercano in cui tutto va a
rallentatore Ma tu hai la piena
coscienza il tuo corpo di te stesso sai
quello che devi fare e lo fai al meglio
in quel momento che ti passa tutta la
vita davanti di quello che hai fatto
di tutti i tuoi sforzi della prima volta
che magari sei salito in bicicletta o
sulla tavola da surf perché in quel
momento c'era la consapevolezza che stai
vincendo che ce l'hai fatta
bene nello sport questo
racchiude un po' tutta No quello che
dovrebbe essere anche un messaggio per
noi nella vita di tutti i giorni a volte
le cose si decidono in frazioni di
secondo in quelle frazioni di secondo
dobbiamo compensare far confluire tutte
quelle che sono le nostre esperienze
passate tutto quello che è stato
il nostro sforzo per arrivare fino a
quel momento tutto quanto se non
riusciamo a fare bene in quel momento le
cose cambiano cambiano in modo positivo
e lui quel giorno dell'essere un
campione è passato ad essere una
leggenda dello sport e oggi la fase
rasoio di 50 anni vi dico che lui vince
ancora
bene
passiamo Però anche a quello che è un
evento negativo una drammaticità perché
la vita non è fatta solo di grandi
campioni vittorie dagli eventi alle
quali ero abituata anch'io fino a poco
tempo fa
Ma ci sono anche eventi drammatici Che
ti obbligano a cambiare
sono eventi che ti buttano giù nel buio
nel buio più profondo sono quei momenti
in cui tu senti e sai solamente quello
che tu non sei più
non sai più definirti per quello che sei
né per quello che sarai sei
completamente perso
e in quel buio profondo ritrovare la
capacità di rivedere la luce non è
semplice non è facile io non sapevo come
fare
assolutamente
questo evento negativo nella mia vita è
arrivato nel 2010 in un caldissimo
giorno d'estate in cui una signora mi ha
tagliato la strada
e non solo in modo figurato ma mi ha
tagliato anche le gambe perché da quel
giorno non ho camminato infatti oggi
sono qui a parlarvi da una carrozzina
questo questo evento negativo è
innescato quello che è stato il periodo
più difficile della mia vita veramente
più buio è stato un periodo in cui ho
sperimentato il più grande dolore
dolore
psicologico che si fonde col dolore
fisico è una cosa difficile da spiegare
perché bisogna veramente solamente
passarci in questi momenti ho
sperimentato
quella sensazione di dire Ok per me è
finita basta basta
Perché il dolore era grande perché lo
sconforto era grande perché sentivo voci
intorno a me che dicevano Nole non ce la
poteva fare mai è impossibile i medici
infermieri
perché ero sotto forti sedativi e quando
ero sotto forti sedativi sentivo tutto
questo e lo vivevo come se fosse un
incubo ad occhi aperti e in quella
situazione capì anche
che cosa mi era accaduto
questo perché perché avevo visto un film
Million Dollar Baby di Clint Eastwood
che raccontava la storia di questa
pugile che aveva che durante un incontro
arrivò Purtroppo ad un punto nel quale
l'avversario gli sfiorò a tradimento Un
colpo al collo e da quel giorno lei
rimase tetraplegica non potevano muovere
nelle braccia nelle gambe quindi la
situazione anche peggiore della mia ma
sapevo che cosa voleva dire una lesione
finale
e lei arrivo il film finisce così che
lei insieme al suo allenatore decidono
di farla finita la aiutano a morire
perché lei non ce la poteva fare non
avevano ancora io invece ho deciso che
non volevo morire ma anzi che volevo
vivere e voi vi chiederete Sì ok belle
parole ma come hai fatto beh preparando
questo Talk che io c'ho pensato
moltissimo ho riflettuto molto su questo
ho detto no bisogna che do
effettivamente
ehm l'idea reale di quello che è
accaduto dentro di me quali sono state
le cose che effettivamente mi hanno
fatto fare quel click cioè dal passare
dal dire ok basta a dire No io voglio
stare qui e ci voglio stare anche bene
bene che cosa è stato mentre ero lì
rianimazione ho detto No di là Ci sono
delle persone che mi vogliono bene
iniziare ad aspetto sono i miei
familiari i miei amici ho i loro
supporto stanno pregando per me perché
io rimango qui con loro
e in più c'era una vocina dentro di me e
gli infermieri che parlavano ho detto No
io devo ripartire dal piacere delle
piccole cose dal mangiare una succosa
albicocca dal rimettermi lo smalto rosso
perché me l'hanno messo veramente mentre
rianimazione lo smalto l'ho chiesto per
darmi un tono un po' di colore per
riprendere un po' la mia femminilità e
in più rivedere il mio amatissimo mare
bene Questo era solo l'inizio le piccole
cose la base della Nuova Marina Ma io
avevo bisogno di qualcosa di più di
ricostruire veramente me stessa e questo
momento di consapevolezza è arrivato in
un giorno in cui hanno un convegno sullo
sport e incontrare una psicoterapeuta
che parla della sua esperienza personale
professionale nell'aiuto ai malati
oncologici per superare il dolore quel
dolore cronico che i farmaci
effettivamente non riescono a curare
bene Ho detto ok c'è qualcosa che io
posso fare ma mi serve l'aiuto di
qualcuno
E così ho trovato una psicologa vicino
casa mia e con lei abbiamo ricostruito
un po' quello che doveva essere il mio
percorso tramite piccoli obiettivi uno
dietro l'altro un piccolo passo alla
volta perché è nella nostra routine in
quello che noi facciamo ogni giorno che
ricostruiamo anche parti della nostra
personalità della nostra autostima a
piccoli pezzi uno dopo l'altro
e i miei primi piccoli pezzi Quali sono
stati iscrivermi
all'esame di ammissione per l'università
cercare una nuova casa dove potessi
essere veramente indipendente
e impegnarmi negli eventi della Marina
Romoli Onlus che è la mia fondazione
perché all'inizio era stata aperta per
me ma io alla fine ho detto No dobbiamo
fare qualcosa per gli altri perché vive
la mia stessa esperienza ma non ha
Magari il supporto che ho ricevuto io
grazie al mondo dello Sport
bene tutto questo
implica una grande forza un grande
coraggio perché il cambiamento come ho
detto all'inizio
implica perdere una parte di noi no
implica perdere la sicurezza il comfort
dobbiamo superare quella zona di comfort
del tutto è sempre stato così tutto ha
sempre fatto quel corso lì
per essere noi al cento per cento
dobbiamo abbandonare questa idea di
Confort e abbracciare la complessità
delle cose anche quando guardiamo
qualcuno si è diverso da noi non
possiamo lo sguardo interessiamoci che
magari scopriamo veramente qualcosa che
non pensavamo nemmeno prima no che ci
potesse interessare in qualche modo
non facciamoci prendere dalla foga di
dover rispettare quelli che sono le
convenzioni sociali o di prendere una
via nella nostra vita che rispetta
solamente gli interessi degli altri ma
non il nostro che non ci fa essere
veramente felici La felicità sta nelle
piccole cose non è uno stato nell'essere
Queste sono delle piccole immagini di
quello che è stata la mia ricostruzione
fare delle piccole cose in cui mi sono
divertita in cui ero proprio mi sono
riappropriata di me stessa fare nuovi
sport che non potevo fare prima
dell'incidente Come fare wakeboard o
andare sul gruppo in mezzo al mare
e anche i simboli hanno un grandissimo
valore nella nostra vita il prima Questo
è il prima e il dopo la mia cicatrice
che è il segno del mio dolore più grande
che corre tutto lungo la mia spina
dorsale
e in sopra che cosa ha voluto fare ho
voluto far crescere una rosa piena di
spine come le sfide dolorose che ho
dovuto passare ma la rosa è sbocciata
come volevo che sbocciasse la mia voglia
di vivere
volevo concludere questo mio discorso
con una citazione di del drammaturgo
Jodorowsky e dirvi che dobbiamo
smetterla di definirci e concederci
tutte le potenzialità dell'essere perché
noi non siamo esseri definiti non siamo
forme e solide definiti ma siamo più che
altro dei liquidi siamo come l'acqua
siamo capaci di fluire di cambiare e in
questo momento vi chiedo avete cambiato
idea rispetto a quello che erano le
domande all'inizio
sì o no
bene grazie a tutti
avete veramente fatto di me
qualcosa di importante perché mi state
dando moltissimo perché fare un Ted era
qualcosa
che per me rappresentava molto un sogno
Grazie a tutti Buona serata
[Applauso]